así fueron recibidos los restos de los
dos periodistas españoles y el
conservacionista irlandés que fueron
asesinados en burkina faso los cuerpos
llegaron a la base aérea de torrejón de
ardoz donde los esperaba la ministra de
exteriores de españa y una
representación diplomática de irlanda
studies
y el roberto que tanto han hecho tanto
han hecho por dar voz a los que no la
tienen tanto han hecho para esclarecer
realidades que nos rodean y que a veces
son invisibles y con ello tanto han
hecho por dar a nuestra democracia la
fuerza que necesita los periodistas
españoles fueron identificados como
david beriáin de 44 años y roberto
fraile de 47 quienes rodeaban un
documental sobre la caza furtiva junto
con el conservacionista irlandés rory
young cofundador de la ong ecologísta
cheng eta wildlife los extranjeros
viajaban con efectivos de las fuerzas
armadas en el oriente del país cuando el
convoy en el que se desplazaban fue
atacado por un grupo armado los tres
extranjeros y un burkinés fueron
asesinados en la emboscada en un
comunicado conjunto españa francia
alemania e italia condenaron los
asesinatos y reiteraron su compromiso
con el sahel la lucha contra el
terrorismo los tráficos ilícitos y todas
las formas de violencia constituyen un
objetivo esencial para garantizar el
estado de derecho y la coexistencia
pacífica de los angelinos
el gobierno de burkina faso señaló que
ningún grupo armado ha reclamado la
autoría del ataque pero medios españoles
aseguraron que se trataría de una
organización relacionada con al qaeda